lot of things has been have been going
on with the stunks mike the stock
markets are just
uh the memes the memes have have been
great people are mad as you can see what
if gamestop was a dirty trick pulled by
some vigor like steve bannon
or his boy genius bitcoin crony to [ __ ]
with biden's administration before they
could get on its feet
uh and uh we don't have her to explain
the stock market to us
she won't return my calls or might pick
messages
okay this is my favorite yeah this is my
favorite is the guy's the girl is chick
man she wouldn't
she wouldn't uh give me no play she must
be a [ __ ]
what a
clearly that is the only reason why she
won't suck your dick she's clearly a
dick
well we want to explain kind of what's
going on with this stuff and we've had
our we
had been a couple of years since we've
had not cia steven had him on for a
little bit this morning and he seemed to
understand uh this [ __ ]
more than i did so uh
you know he is he is qualified i'm going
to have him explain his qualifications
uh
our buddy not cia steve hey what's going
on pal
gents how are you what's going on doing
good now why don't you
not much what are your qualifications
talking to you buddy hey how are you
i am hey i'm doing all right i am not
active but i am
a my my license is active i just have to
find a trading house but i have a series
seven brokers item so
if you ever make a trade i'm usually the
guy who would do it for you
did you have a chinese guy go do the
test for you like chris maltasanti
no actually i did it all on my own we
cubans are
an intelligent group for that scene
where they're like maltesante and he's
like here he's like some little chinese
guys
okay so first off are you in a wind
tunnel
no i'm walking a dog i'm sorry i tried
the best that i could but she is driving
me crazy so you get to
deal with a little bit of wind i'm gonna
do my best not to but the cold front is
coming through so
i'm gonna try and like stay out of here
oh my god a cold front what is it going
to
hit
58 degrees 40 something it is icy icy
gold i need to get my parking
yeah so uh
real quick quick rundown you don't have
to do the whole explanation this morning
but quick run
yeah i'm not i'm not doing another two
hours what yeah your adderall's wearing
off
so what
what exactly happened with gamestop for
people that don't understand
yeah long story short uh what ended up
happening was back in september
a hedge fund a known hedge fund released
their trades
and usually what you see is that people
kind of copy their trades
and a couple of day traders looking to
take revenge on some hedge funds
saw an opportunity and they saw what's
called a short position a short position
very very high level understanding here
it's
when you borrow a stock betting that
it's going to go lower so that you get
to buy it at the lower price
and then the other guy has to make the
difference up to you that was on the
other side of the bet that's
generally how that works so these guys
on wall street bets
who they produce like cool little day
trading information and
you know analysis isn't bad they saw an
opportunity
they weaponized redditors who have
access to robin hood accounts td
ameritrade e-trade
schwab you know basic stock buying
platforms and said hey
look they're in a short position so go
pump the stock basically let's buy them
out of their short position and so what
that means
you're betting that the stock price will
go down in a short position
so someone's you know betting obviously
the other way if you can get the price
to go up by the time that that position
was supposed to go
down then you're gonna end up costing
that person a lot of money
and as i was telling royce this morning
there's a limitless potential of losses
right so like in a normal stock play on
a lot what we call a long play
if i just bought stock right what's the
most that i could lose
however much i spent on the stock right
if i buy a thousand dollars worth of
stock
i can only lose a thousand dollars
there's no negative stock
return that i'm gonna have to pay out
but in short because you're betting it
at a floor
like you're saying hey it's only going
to go to 20 if the stock goes to six
hundred dollars
you owe the difference per share of five
hundred and eighty dollars per share you
buy a billion you know a million shares
of that
you're going to owe a [ __ ] ton of money
so that's what happened
well this got out of control real fast
uh which normally happens when anything
goes viral
it got so far out of control that the
trading platforms
which i think is kind of where a lot of
the questions are going to come for
today
they had to step in and finally restrict
or shut down trading
to potential targeted stocks because
what's being done is called a stock
squeeze or short squeeze excuse me
so a short squeeze is is the operation
you take down a short position
and they found like five different
positions that they think
anyway are potential squeezes and so the
market's pissed everybody's pissed
and now the government's going to try
and step in elizabeth warren thinks she
has an opportunity it's just gotten
so far out of control and it basically
made some people sit out of money and
it's killing a lot of others
so yeah so that's what's happened so
what's happening is right now
um robin hood uh robin hood
and a couple other uh sites have stopped
you from buying
from buying any shares in uh
in gamestop in gamestop and they are
actually
for selling stuff for some people i've
been seeing that going around too
so they've been yeah so what's happening
there um you know and this is i think
you'd asked me about that earlier like
what is this it's probably happening
it's an agreement that you
that anybody who signs up makes uh
there's a fiduciary responsibility that
all brokers
have it's a question on the test it's on
two tests that i have to take there's a
series 66 which i have
and a series seven and it gets repeated
over and over that you have a fiduciary
responsibility
to not let things get out of control for
your investor
what does that mean well it goes back to
2008 and
even further into 2001 right these are
dodd-frank's rules these are government
rules that got placed onto the market
and said
this got out of control back in the 80s
of savings and loan you don't get to do
this again because what can i do as a
trader
i could tell you what to buy right which
is pretty much what happened
right but that's what it is i could turn
around and go listen i know the market
better than you just give me all your
money
because i'm going to take a commission
anyway you're going to lose your ass but
who cares i'm still getting your money
right so the government said no no no
you have to do what's in their best
interest not your best interest
so robin hood operates as a broker just
like me so if you were to come to
you know steve's investment house or
whatever then i'm your broker and you
would put your money with me it's no
different than what robin hood's doing
just robin hood
is faceless right it's just an app but
there's somebody on the other side of
that
app who when you submit your trade is
actually doing the trade for you
you're not doing the trade the broker's
doing the trade on your behalf
so they have a fiduciary responsibility
robin hood
also is trying to do their own ipo so
there's like some more
underground stuff here that's starting
to bubble up that might make the optics
even worse
for robin hood well robin hood robin
hood right now has
i believe two class action lawsuits
because of this
yes i saw that now they did agree to
open up gamestop tomorrow
but they're going to limit it oh how
nice and how nice of them to
allow people to trade what they want
there's this big thing i was telling
royce this morning
it's such a weird microcosm of things
that are going on because so many
different sides are involved
when ted cruz is retweeting aoc
you know that the apocalypse is right on
our doorstep
well it's not only that he's retweeting
her but you saw he retweeted her and
then she
and then she tweeted him back and she
was like you literally tried to have me
killed and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening like yeah she
accused him of murder
because these yeah go ahead i'm sorry no
that's it
yeah so so you know it's so why is robin
hood allowed to
push out trades that you're not
approving because when you sign up with
anybody to do investments for you
we have you do a risk tolerance and uh
richton's questionnaire survey however
you want to call it and you answer a
handful of questions
that basically tell us how risk-averse
you are right
maybe you're somebody who doesn't like
to make bets well you're going to make
that clear
in a series of questions that shows us
you're relatively risk-averse
okay so then if you're getting involved
in a stock that is
blowing up and is unbelievably volatile
we have permission to sell you out of
your portfolio
to rebalance everything and that's what
they're doing yeah well they're doing
that but
right the optics are bad the optics the
objects are super bad but i you know
my thing is is that seeing a lot of
these
entrenched headphone managers and all
these people
losing their minds is hilarious to me uh
you know we talked about it but you know
jeremy c owens the guy from market watch
uh he tweeted out
gamestop is not a 10 billion dollar
company full stop okay
was he a 15 year old girl oh that's the
guy that had to protect his thread and
everything because he was getting
just bombarded on twitter gamestop is
not a 10 billion dollar company
full stop and everyone involved in all
of this knows that
yet there's unsophisticated investors
you [ __ ] everyone
you know us unwashed plebeians yeah you
[ __ ] you
the unwashed masses investors out here
seeing all this fun wsb
is having and buying the [ __ ] out of it
and this is my favorite line
it will not end well stop laughing
but like honestly aren't the people at
wall street bets
just doing the same thing that all of
these people do
anyway like it's yeah it was fine
yeah it was fine when they were doing it
when they were playing their little
inside baseball
but when a couple guys [ __ ] just
threw them out molotov cocktail into the
machine
now it's a pro now it's like hey guys
this is irresponsible we shouldn't be
we shouldn't we shouldn't be using the
stock market to do a bunch of
wild speculative plays and it's like
well no no
no no no no that's what you've been
doing for 20 years and then getting a
bailouts
with our [ __ ] money whenever you [ __ ]
it up so
like what it's it is kind of [ __ ]
that it's they're get they're getting
[ __ ] they're basically being
um disavowed for doing the same thing
the guys that they're [ __ ] with do
and before you go see mark marketwatch
also said marketwatch also tweeted this
is the same guy runs the account
you might think it's funny to value
gamestop like it's 2007 again and hurt
some hedge funds
in the process but you might not think
the next target is funny nor the next
nor the next now i want to be that was
also
jeremy owens who wrote that article yeah
so i want to be clear yes i'm going to
think it's funny and i'm going to think
that next is funny yeah
and the next and the next because when
people were [ __ ] losing their homes
and parents couldn't when when the
[ __ ] market crashed and people
couldn't go to work
and people couldn't buy food for their
[ __ ] family you [ __ ] got a
bailout so i think it's hilarious
well that the people on twitter too was
funny because the guy goes
yeah well you know what when some kid
logs into his dad's
account and and uh wipes out his uh all
of his funds with uh you know
options trading on gamestop or or if
some guy tells you later that he lost
his entire life savings putting it in
the game stop
you're not going to be laughing and the
reply one after another every reply was
i would laugh hysterically i would think
that was the funniest [ __ ] ever i'm
sorry like
maybe i'm evil but if somebody said to
me
yeah i uh i watched this gamestop [ __ ]
unfold and i was like wow that's crazy
so i took my entire life savings and
bought gamestop at
bucks and lo i would laugh hysterically
at that person i'd go that
that was the worst thing you could have
possibly done look look i wanted to
short game stop yesterday
and i would have made a fortune but i
didn't because
you're like i this this is a scary thing
to
this anything can happen right now so i
didn't do it well but here's
here's what marshall so you're you're
approaching this differently than most
and i think this is
a lot of what gets kind of lost in in
the din of
you know how dare these hedge funds get
upset which
is right i mean it is a bit hypocritical
the problem is
like you said i can just go short it now
right but the people doing this who are
being weaponized
they don't understand it right they're
doing this thinking
i'll find any short position i can and
blow it up
no because the minute you cleared 150 to
200
a share the guys who you thought you
were taking down just bought more short
positions
at a hundred right because they know
this is coming back down eventually
yes and when it does they're gonna win
and they're gonna cover their spread
and that's the difference right well
it's like they did during the housing
crisis wildly volatile
yeah no go ahead sorry oh i was just
gonna say
options trading is is dangerous and very
volatile
and people love it because it makes a
lot of money really quick
right because in the essence you're just
basically doing sports betting for
stocks
and picking you know you're doing
squares or you're doing lines
whatever just as you would with a sports
bet line but you're doing it for
stocks and you make a lot of money
really really quick when you watch shows
like billions and [ __ ] like that
you're like oh i could be like this
these guys are
these guys aren't anything special well
i'm not gonna say they're special but
they understand the risks a little bit
better so what td ameritrade did that
robin hood should have done but i just
don't think the platform is built for it
is forced the margin covers right so in
essence if you try to jump into an
option call um
with team america says if you're going
to do this you better have
every dollar possible to cover this if
this fails
and they don't like make it trade
otherwise so you have to show them and
that's how a lot of hedge funds work
like hey we're going to need 25
dollars because you could lose a good
chunk of money
so you have to be ready for that so
you're not putting in you know your life
savings like you just said
unfortunately too many people don't
understand this they're greedy
or want to just make money which is not
really greedy i can understand it we're
in a little panemic
right and they want to just not die or
lose their house
so they saw an opportunity and they
jumped along with it so yeah you're
right
the guys on reddit were doing exactly
what the hedge funds do
but they did it in in in too volatile
manner
i guess is the better way that that's
what's causing the cnbc guys and
everybody else to go
you've got to pump the brakes on this
because market manipulation could be
done
but not like this this is dangerous and
this can get wildly out of control and
then you're looking at an 08 situation
because it's no different than houses
it's just small that's all
yeah it's i a lot of people are going to
get left holding that stock now too
and that was that was the one thing that
i i tried to point out even on my other
show i was like look
i'm i'm here for this i think it's
hilarious i'm going to watch it unfold
i'm going to cover it whatever but
you know i tried to explain to people
i'm like anybody can have
a short position not just a hedge fund
so i'm like you know there were a lot of
people too that just got
wiped out and that had short positions
on gamestop
so it's like you know because it made
sense like it was this thing
it's really funny it is funny it is
funny because what's going on here
is the short position itself i mean i
was telling royce
like in 20 years someone's going to talk
about
gamestop in a historical sense that's
ridiculous
okay but game stops making history
because it's this
open vehicle for a movement and really
what it is is it's showing an expletive
hole
right like hey look here's a a little
quirk in the system
that these guys took for granted that
nobody
would call them on sometimes some day
traders were pretty intelligent
and understand the way the game gets
played weaponized a bunch of people who
don't understand how the game gets well
and it's funny when
you get to their advantage it's funny
with the weaponizing like you know this
tweet was i thought was hilarious it's a
picture of biden and it was just
big chungus 420 anime feet sniffer and
zoomer girl
are just a few of the financial
terrorists who have sunk this american
economy
it is hilarious going through it and
seeing the names that are doing this
i think it's [ __ ] amazing look i i
understand
kitty or whatever i think is the main
this is the lead call
yeah on this uh on the operations i
think one of them was
like thick dad if there may be any
questions i'm sorry
i think one of them was like was like
[ __ ] thick dad or whatever on reddit
it is it is very it is very funny uh
well i i i have a question um because
yesterday i was gonna short gamestop uh
but they wanted like
eight grand and i was like i'm not doing
that yeah and then i didn't short it
and if i had shorted that i would have
made thousands of dollars today i guess
my question is why
am i a [ __ ]
you're not you're actually pretty it's
just it's a risk tolerance right and
it's funny because when i was
when i was investing we're doing
investments here as an advisor um
almost overwhelmingly anybody who's
young
has a higher risk tolerance than the
people who don't right like you know
degenerate gamblers well their risk
tolerance is pretty high
right they're willing to just take it
all and see what the hell happens
you're later in your life where you
understand the value of a dollar
right and you also understand that that
dollar is not going to always be there
so you want to keep whatever dollars you
have so yeah you're willing to take a
little bit of risk
but you're not willing to run it because
you also look at it and go i know me
like i told royces
if i bought on if i'd bit on uh bitcoin
bitcoin would be worth 15 cents right
now because i bet on it
every because everybody else does it
it's like 38 000
uh well that's how i feel i'm the king
of but i'm like i love
crypto and i'm the king of like watching
something and then going all right i'm
in
and then i'll buy and the minute i buy
it's just red candles
hang [ __ ]
it is like it's this like narcissistic
thing but everyone does that where
you're just like
it's me it's because i bought it it's
literally because got it because god
hates me absolutely
bitcoin would be 15 cents if i buy it
tomorrow
well could you do me a favor could we
can you call me after the show we'll
work something out i'll short the [ __ ]
out of it yeah
and then you can just and buy one
yeah most of the shorts right now are
going to cost you 100 of the margin so
if you
you're they're going to try to set you
on what's called a spread so they're
going to want you to block everything
uh so you're going to need like 13 000
to pull off even a small position
yeah that's why i was so pissed
yesterday i was like oh i was like i got
a couple hundred i'll do a nice little
quick short
and they're like yeah we want eighty six
hundred dollars and i'm like
no yeah and if you you know if you had
gone long into the position
like just buy a regular stock buy right
you would have already lost
if you put in a hundred dollars you
would have lost 900 bucks or
900 excuse me 100 shares then he would
have lost like 900 bucks today
uh talking like that toxic avengers
calling you uh
mercies the sheep of wall street
uh there's some questions here you can
send your question to streamlabs.com
revenge of the sis how about that i will
say this
you people that were holding the line
yesterday
are a bunch of [ __ ] marks because
right now okay see
thank you that's the problem right and
that's [ __ ] rude
i was screaming at people to sell
yesterday i'm like sell it it's that 350
dollars
you bought it for 40. just [ __ ] sell
it
yeah can you can you guys hear me did i
leave your friend you're good
okay um yeah you want to know what you
said is exactly why
they're getting the attention from the
government and from the regulators
is because of these idiots you're
screaming hold the line we'll bring them
down
you're not beating a hedge fund they got
a 30 million capital injection if you
know somebody who can give you 30
million dollars on the fly
knock yourself out but trust me you
don't well hey
hey steve can i borrow 30 million
dollars i was just going to do this
all right yeah see we're good please and
thank you
oh by the way royce i did use i did use
all of rotc's money
uh to buy gamestop wait what no no you
can't do that
then we're going to all the bank money
because i used all of it for amc
listen oh boy see because that's the
problem now you guys understand how
short it's
keep borrowing against each other yeah i
bought at 346 yesterday
i put all of our money in at 346
yesterday it's down to 193 but it's
gonna bounce
i feel a nice bounce coming on any
minute now how many people right now
we're looking at this again
look they're going it's gonna and and
right now they're still not
selling it that's the worst part is
they're going no it's gonna
i'm telling you maybe honestly that's
the problem they honestly think that
this operation
is going to do so here's about son royce
earlier if they just held the stock like
let's say
everybody who buys in is all in on wall
street bets and this concept that they
will
demolish the head fund a hedge fund
hedge fund guys by holding onto the
stock and forcing them
to meet margin calls okay fine and
you're still holding a stock that's
going to be worthless at the end of
march
yeah yeah i know i mean gamestop has to
release quarterly
they're not selling anything it's still
gamestop in the end
uh you should dress a piece of [ __ ] up
it's still [ __ ] excuse me but i want to
go buy a used madden
2021 right now and i could go to
gamestop right now and get it for more
expensive than i could buy it on uh
downloading it from my xbox yeah i'm
sorry but who else is going to give me
11 cents for my old ds game yeah 11
easily if that if that so take that okay
you would think that stock would be
incredibly valuable for the shitty
[ __ ]
shifty business practices they've done
all these years and i'm sorry steve but
i need to buy one of those madcatz
controller that i let
my friend use when he comes over i'm not
going to give him the good one you know
ziggy uses no no you never give him the
good one you give him the original one
that came with the system yeah here have
this piece of [ __ ] i'll have the good
one
but you know now some somebody asked
that's a good question
even if they stop at what's stopping
like china from do from continuing doing
this now with russia from doing this
in the market capital injections well so
eventually
they're just because like it goes
actually back to my earlier point they
did it they're doing it by losing money
you're just going to lose money
right because eventually these store
these companies are just going to go
bankrupt
and they're not going to have anything
people don't understand you're not
giving money
that's like you know goes back to a
mercer saying there's idiots on there
hold the line we're saving these
companies
no you're not okay you're not you're not
buying stock
from them they're not getting like your
money out of this they're just looking
at a higher stock value which
if they had a plan to somehow turn their
company around and not be based
in the 2000s anymore yeah they could
release stock and dilute the stock price
and
have a whole lot of liquidity and that'd
be cool but they're not because they
don't because their games stop
well
if they're putting in money russia china
whoever you're just dumping it into a
hall that you're going to end up losing
because when the company goes bankrupt
stocks worthless yeah
well gamestop from what i read did um
they did sell
um sell off some shares like in a pin
because they were like this is great
of course yeah they sold awesome shares
because they were like oh man we needed
this
we needed this money well they had they
they had reserve shares because they
didn't know how far this was going to go
and so so
most of these companies have like
reserve and restricted stairs that they
have kind of in the waiting if they need
to
they just kind of released a little bit
out there to depress that's the market a
smidge to just
kind of let it flow a little bit and
they didn't nobody knew how far this
would get
right that's the thing the minute this
thing started getting viral
is when it became a problem because it
was viral and it's a stock
that was unbelievably cheap just like
express uh
uh what is the other cost which is a
headphones company
right um um what is the other nokia
blackberry right these are cheap stocks
so when it's viral
and someone's telling you hey man for a
hundred dollars
you can make a hundred thousand how you
who's gonna say no to that
right you're gonna be all in on that
holy [ __ ] 100 bucks [ __ ] no problem here
you go i got that on my unemployment
check
there you go i don't i don't think i
don't think anybody was i mean maybe
some but i think most people weren't
going into it thinking they were going
to save gamestop because let's be
realistic gamestop didn't have a good
rap to begin with
some of them maybe but for the most part
i look gamestop was gonna fail anyway
right i think this was just a way to
to [ __ ] with the system with a company
that's already inevitably an ilk man
let's be honest
in two years his gamestop gonna be
around probably not
you know i doubt it i mean very unlikely
no you're you're not wrong right and
that's why you're not seeing
the other shorted positions taking off
like
gamestop gamestop the only reason this
worked is probably because melvin
capital
when he released or when they released
their that that particular fund manager
said like hey here's our our you know
our market movements
he made it clear it was a naked short he
didn't have a spread
covering his his potentiality of loss
because the idea was it's [ __ ] game
stop
where's it gonna go yeah no right
that's what happened and and somebody
took advantage of it he just saw an
opportunity
yeah no they did and um the
so what do you what do you think happens
now like do you think that there
i know i asked it before but i'll ask
again obviously new people listen do you
think that
there'll be any legislation passed
because of this um unfortunately sherrod
brown
who is the uh treasury count or
yeah the chair of the committee of some
kind or another he's already wanting to
do an investigation
uh is this is the wind really bad i'm
sorry no you're good you're good
okay cool yeah uh elizabeth warren oh
god she drove me nuts she was on cnbc
and she got some pushback which i really
liked from the analysts
um or the reporters but she was talking
about hey you see this is why we need to
get the sec to make a
final definition as to what market
manipulation looks like
i mean that's just not like this is
inviting
regulation yeah what i really think is
gonna
probably happen is the sec will stop
we'll step in on the option side
and not allow over leveraging anymore i
don't know how
um but i was telling you earlier with um
mike you or mercy you can you can you
can over
leverage stop a short position because
remember the
the losses are limitless right so you
can over leverage at 100
i think the float was like 121 percent
the last time i checked
so that means that over 121 percent of
the shares are being
you know shorted well how's it possible
the company's only 100 percent
right you can't over you can't make more
of the company i don't get to make a
fifth of the company extra
to short so you know there's that
there's that little
cork in the system so maybe because
that's really what ended up killing
melvin capital was the fact that they
were so over leveraged into this
position
well and i think that that's why the
game stop uh one was
one of the only ones that really um was
successful because
it was the most over leveraged and
people
saw that weakness and they were like oh
we could wipe these guys out in a day
as opposed to some of the other ones
where like you said they're more covered
or
you know they they have some kind of um
um
what do you call it um what's the word
i'm looking collateral or whatever
backing it so it's like not as
volatile but yeah the gamestop one was
one of those where it was just this
rickety house of cards and they were
like
oh my god dude they have way they're
leveraged more
than there are actual shares and i think
that was why they targeted gamestop so
hard
it was because they didn't have it
covered right and again it just goes
back to the hubris of the hedge funds
and there there's the argument right
that royce was talking about earlier you
guys are both talking about where
hey this isn't that's where market watch
screws up
and all these optics look bad when
they're like hey stop blasting this is
funny what is kind of funny because the
hubris of the hedge fund guys
is what's causing this right somebody
got a little
too complacent and said who the hell
gives a [ __ ] what i'm
about to do with game stop it's friggin
gamestop right
and so they just did a short sale which
it was inevitably going to happen it's
kind of like listen
your grandma's dying we're going to find
a way to pump granny for a couple of
dollars before she goes out right that's
all this was
this was just an opportunity to take a
dying body in gamestop and make a little
cash off it
well they left their position open they
should have never announced it honestly
and they did and some other guys were
even smarter and said oh you want to
beat up on grandma we'll take care of
that for you
no and you're right and you know and
it's funny because i don't know if you
saw this
uh this this guy tim
uh this guy uh howard lindsen
who was one of the seed investors for
for ra for
robin hood so he tweeted out uh seat
investor
at robin hood really novice investors
playing one of the most complex games in
the world using leverage
surprised that the rules get changed on
the mid game
precious i have been there head back to
your mom's basement in roblox or get or
get better at the game
this is the kind of stuff this is the
kind of [ __ ] stuff that makes people
aggravated when you talk which i don't
understand because he created a platform
that allows them
to do what they were arguing for which
is democratizing the investment
yeah but the thing is is it's this is
what i said on my show last night too
is that these people that are that run
the markets and stuff
they they want you to lose they're okay
if you're doing this losing they don't
care
but like now they're playing it off like
they're like see this
is what happens you could lose money i
tried to tell you and it's like
you want people to lose money you want
people to sign up for your app and
everybody everybody
wants like you know even when i like
[ __ ] around trade with crypto like
you you want dumb ass rookies to enter
the market that's where you get your
liquidity that's how you make money and
that's how you get somebody to buy
something
that's overvalued from you so it's like
people want the rookies in there and
they're like
oh yeah no open up an account play play
a little bit with your little money
put throw throw a couple 100 in there
and play around in the stock
like they literally will say play around
in the stock market they're okay with
taking your money
but the minute you [ __ ] again throw a
molotov cocktail into the machine
they're like
you know this is this isn't funny and
you're like no it's actually this guy
it's so you're you're you're not you're
not wrong hang on because it's important
to know this this part of it this is a
thing that a lot of people miss on this
is in the end robin hood td ameritrade
these are still brokerage houses that
need assets under management
right that's the goal for any house when
i used to work for my firm
with assets under management they can't
have you lose money
they just don't want you to try and make
too much of it right and the reason for
that is
if you get if you go ape [ __ ] right then
you're just going to try and say well i
know how to do this on my own you're
going to leave
okay well now you're going to take your
assets with you same thing on the other
side of that right
robin hood can't have these people start
losing too much money
because you're going to leave the
platform you're going to say you let me
do this
why did you let me do this and that's
why robin hood is literally stuck
between a rock and a hard place
because they moved on this way too
slowly okay
that's where the issue comes from and
the argument it goes back to 2008
because that's the other end of this
problem i was telling royce that this
isn't something that happened over a
week
right this has been a growing problem
for 20 years and that it's just now
coming to fruition
and that's what the last from 2008 going
forward or whatever the tea party
started 2010
um you know it's this idea this growing
frustration
with elites saying no no no we have this
and do what we tell you to do
and then they get mad when you do that
because somebody took advantage or
misunderstood and then they turn around
and they blame them
and the elites are like well fine then
we're gonna be even more protective and
so
what ended up happening like with 2008
is nobody ever looked in
to the toxic assets except like a
handful of people
right in the movie uh the big short and
said no
no guys this is really [ __ ] terrible
don't touch this stuff
everyone's like no buy houses buy more
houses
buy 12 houses you're a stripper buy
eight houses this is the best thing you
could do because you know what
housing's going to the moon right so
you're going to make a ton of money
and everything died right and we almost
had a collapse where we would have been
blade runner or something
so you know so now they're they're over
protecting
right their position by saying hey look
we let it get too far last time so now
we're going to jump way ahead and say
please listen to us you don't know any
better and that's why
this the the optics are so bad at this
when they just need to kind of slow down
and say
let me explain to you what's happening
and then yeah make your own decision
that's how the market works
and that and i think that's the bottom
line i i think that's the bottom line
whether you agree with
whether you don't you should have the
same rights as any hedge funds people do
you should have the option if it isn't
right
they've been touting the free market
tied in the free market whether you
think it's a good decision or not that
shouldn't really matter
but what's happening now what you're
seeing with robinhood we've seen all
these people it's like you know what you
when you're in a casino
and you're winning too much so they ask
you to leave this is what's happening
people are like they're they're [ __ ]
their system up they're not playing
their little day trading games like when
these [ __ ] go on cnbc
when they they're when these when these
when these hedge fund uh
hedge fund people go on cnbc that are
the analysts yeah the analysts
they're about to show or they're
shorting a stock and they go you know
this company [ __ ] sucks
and they help the stock go under not
saying the stock wasn't going to go
under anyway
they have the right to do that and
that's fine let them do it but the fact
that up when a bunch of [ __ ]
redditors in their quote-unquote mom's
basements
get their stimulus check and go hey
let's see what we could do with this
they get angry so yeah and so you
actually make two really good points
two different points number one the
people who are also pushing this are
people like elon musk
why is elon angry because the short
position guys have been screwing his
stock over for years
right right and he may very and the
fundamentals kind of support their
argument
right but elon makes just like portnoy
because the two of them
are really the heavy drivers here right
like portnoy could sit there and say
go buy mouse farts and you will find a
way to buy mouse farts
no matter what happens portnoy says it
he's got an army that will follow his
command
one way or another it's not a good or a
bad thing it's just reality right elon's
got the same thing
so when both of them jump in and they're
like hey this is [ __ ] then every
steve everybody sorry yeah sorry i got
another call
assassinated um yeah it is so when
when uh what they're saying elon well so
when elon says
do this or hey this sucks and everybody
else says hey this
sucks and it's oh well elon said it so
it must be true look how smart elon is
he puts satellites into space and
you know [ __ ] cars with astronauts
and [ __ ] whatever
he builds trucks with windows that break
yeah yeah so the other problem though
royce like you said
there's an unattended consequence here
right which is and i was talking to a
couple buddies this morning
there's a very good chance that this
might prevent the 1400 stimulus checks
to go out
yep because the government who has to
pretend to be your babysitter
is going to say well god if we send this
money out they're just going to do this
[ __ ] all over again
and that's not stimulating the economy
that's literally just pouring money
right back into the same problem that
democrats are going to say is the
enemy in the first place but you know
it's a feedback like we what we talked
about
earlier today though which i thought was
the stimulating economy is a completely
different world like we talked about
remember when bush we talked about bush
another 300
after 9 11 and that money was supposed
to be like oh go go to macy's and go
spend it
those most of these places don't exist
anymore you're not going to go to a
brick and mortar store so your money is
either you're going to give it to amazon
you're going to give it to walmart and
that's pretty much it like and i i'll
also make the argument
that quite frankly if the government
gives me
two thousand dollars and i immediately
spend it on d
gen leverage trading and [ __ ] options
and
wildly speculative cryptocurrency and i
lose every penny of it
i've still spent that money better than
the government will
so [ __ ] them i still want my money okay
it's still better off it's better off
even if i'm the one like just just me
being the one pissing it away
i'd still give me my money [ __ ] like
so i you're you're right if it was your
money right but it's not
it is my money and it's our money right
because
and i want it hear me out let me let me
explain how how i'm seeing this real
quick
so yes it's your money because yeah you
pay taxes too right
so but so do i and so does royce and so
does you know the listeners and and what
have you hopefully
um so the problem is is that that money
is being generated off of a tax base
that now is pumping in more capital
injection
that allows for more stupid trades like
this that creates a feedback loop
that more people are poor so now we've
got to give you more money and you need
to turn around and say i'm going to look
for the next opportunity to make more
money because i need more money and it
just keeps going and going and going and
that's the problem with
the way that the fed is operating
liquidity it's like that's the thing
there's so many little spiders
that connect out to this and create this
massive web that it's extremely
complicated and that's where i was
telling royce this morning
that's how oa kind of got started was
there's so much more behind it it's not
just this easy
hey here's what you should do and you
make a million dollars like a reverse
mortgage or
you know something else you would hear
on am radio or buying gold or whatever
you know like there's more to these
things that are driving the movement
and going and going from one step to the
next step to the next step and that's
you know people like hey why do we bail
out the banks i get it
right the banks are the ones who created
these toxic assets and literally gave
them
to their analysts to push on to other
people like a mortgage-backed security
back in 2005 2006-2007 going into the
crash at 08
right but at the same time without
giving them money we have no monetary
system
and it becomes this too big to fail
which is an argument that
absolutely people should well we
shouldn't have that right yes
right and no because now you're arguing
against the free market and the free
market's allowing
the gobbling of the smaller banks to be
taken on because
why well because the same people who
just got done telling you
too big to fail is a problem and we have
to hit them back is the same party that
argues for raising taxes
which screws small business and those
small businesses are going to be what
bought out by the big banks which
creates a monopoly which creates a too
big to fail situation
so it just keeps going and going and
going and they don't want to admit
that they're [ __ ] part of the problem
so right
if i'm understanding you correctly what
you're saying is we should all invest in
dogecoin am i correct
without question all your money does
coin we're going to
talk to the moon no i mean that no
actually i'll say this unironically yeah
if you guys want to
listen if you guys want to oh i'm going
to invest in the economy and own pieces
of a company
then talk to steve but if you want to
learn how to go
full blown degen on uniswap okay get you
a metamask wallet
you come to me all right you go well in
to start a mining operation where you're
buying out servers and stealing them and
hiding them in a warehouse where you're
jacking the entire electricity of a
small town in indiana
yeah i'm talking about that server baby
start mining bitcoin
buy dogecoin for a tenth of a cent okay
you keep swapping it back and forth for
tether
and by tomorrow you even you
so let me read some i have to read some
of these here yeah sinister charlie
boy that my book you sure is amazing
nods approvingly
uh then mercer's bae rob is gay has does
have a question for steve
uh what if stephen hawking was a real
slim shady but he just couldn't stand up
steve commented i like that um
that's a great that's a great point and
now i'm going to not sleep tonight
thinking about that this is serious
stuff
serious stuff coming in here something
else this is better than the kong versus
godzilla for sure
yeah what if stephen hawking was a slim
shady but he just can't stand
yeah so it throws the entire song away
moral pejorative says
the nazi ia steve guy does
does sound german oh he must be from
argentina i get it wink wink
el sig el essay
all right so i know you can't you can't
offer any financial advice because
obviously you don't want to go to jail
you can't right but if your prison is
not fun for me a prison it's not fun
for anybody i mean i'm assuming he'd be
pulling the [ __ ] andy dufresne in
there i know a lot about money in stocks
he's helping the warning i would find
the warden in a heartbeat do you need me
to just wander some cash for you because
i am more than happy to do so as long as
you keep the sisters off of me yeah
[ __ ] you
i like to say steve they didn't have the
sisters on him
i like to say that but i would love to
see that version but
shawshank where steve goes to jail tries
that and just immediately gets
re-arrested for
trying to privatize oh that would be
hilarious it's nothing like a movie
you're like listen i can help you
launder money uh
did you just offer to okay you know
leaning what um towards me can you say
that again one more time
what was that about money laundering no
here's you
lay it out for me slowly another
question why is biden gonna be the best
president we've ever had
i can't answer that question but you
have to you have to answer it
i think it's an easy answer though like
it's because he's gonna
he he wants to bring people he's the
lord and savior he's gonna
create unity yeah well so we do have a
question for five dollars
like this is the username it's a real
question but here's the username kamala
speckled
says oh my gosh jesus how long do these
hedge funds
that's why he's going to be the best
president how long do these hedge funds
have to keep their shorts open is there
a time limit
where they have to close them out and
then lose a lot or can they just keep
them open until the stock goes down
below what the
they bought it for um that's a good
question so
normally contract positions like options
contracts or a month long
sometimes there are four months long it
depends on how far out you want to buy
it now obviously
you can buy if you buy a longer short
you're betting on stuff that you don't
know so it's no different than like
betting on the buccaneers in the
beginning of the season right
where they were like a massive underdog
in terms of where they were going to get
to
and let me be fair you know who was
saying to bet on the bucks
mike was w
my bookie put all since the beginning of
the season bet on the bucks and nobody
listen to him
bet on the bucks every single week and
here we are
mm-hmm and nowhere in america so so
let's let's talk let's take that as a
great example to kind of answer the
question
um is if i bet on the bucks at the
beginning of the season
yeah there's a huge risk that i could
lose right because the odds were massive
but if i bet on the bucks a week ago to
go to the super bowl well odds are a lot
smaller right there's only two teams in
the championship
one of them is the buccaneers so my odds
are going to be much smaller and
therefore
i'm not going to have as much of a
growth opportunity to make some money
i'm only going to make a smidge amount
of money
right versus if i bet on them in the
beginning of the season so the longer
your short play is
the more volatility there is in terms of
you can either make a lot of money or
you're going to lose
a lot of money sometimes the premiums
are a little bit cheaper
so who you buy the contract off of has a
premium what they'll end up doing
and you see this in the big short
michael bury does it where he just keeps
extending the short play
and keeps just burning cash right and
what he did with his hedge fund
was he kept telling his investors give
me more money i need to keep extending
these right these swaps out these these
credit default swaps
to keep going because eventually this is
going to happen and we're going to make
a billion dollars
well if you're a hedge fund person right
an investor and you're being told
i need another 50 000 to lose you're
like what are you [ __ ] crazy dude and
the guy is just telling you no no
no just hear me out in like a year
you're gonna make a billion dollars
give me another 125k and you're like no
i'm not gonna keep giving you money
right right and so he ended up getting
into a fight with his investors and then
they ended up making a billion dollars
and they're like hey thanks a lot we're
gonna
close the position um so yeah they're
they're usually month contracts if
you're just kind of looking to not get
your ass
killed but they can be as far as three
months out um
it's on the actual ticker it'll show you
when the club the contract closes
and then it'll tell you how much your
premium is and what your strike price is
which is
what you're aiming for um on the target
and then
you just keep if you know the month is
closing you can do one of two things you
can either buy out your position
which is you cover the spread right so
whatever the difference is between where
the stock is at going into the close
and your target price which is normally
relatively close
or you get what's called a margin call
where you let this contract expire you
didn't close the contract
out and that's what the attempt is
against melvin capital
is to make them pay the difference so if
you're at 20
strike price and i think it closed
yesterday at like 325
okay so that's 305 dollars per share
and they're in it for like a million
dollar or a million shares
so melvin would have had to pay day of
305 million dollars
they might not even have that yeah like
that's the problem that's what happens
uh royce that's what happens in trading
places like everyone watches trading
places and doesn't know what the [ __ ] is
going on
they just know dan aykroyd and eddie
murphy end up on a vote right yeah and
that the old guys lose
okay but what's up excuse me spoiler
alert i was just about to watch that
movie
oh i'm sorry you're about 25 years late
yeah so
more than that man 30. yeah yeah yeah 30
30 almost 40 years
actually jesus god we're all old
yeah that's bad so what's going on in
that movie and kind of give you an idea
of what happened to them is exactly what
the attempt
was on melvin capital was they tried to
corner the frozen concentrated orange
juice
market by bringing up the price under
anticipating with their fake data that
dan akroyd provided
um that orange juice was going to be uh
heavily
killed on a freeze so there would be
less supply so if the price is really
really high this is commodities trading
but it's not too different
if the price is really really high and
people need orange juice they're going
to pay your super high price
right that was the idea that the old
guys the dukes were trying to do
but akroyd and the guys and eddie murphy
knew
orange juice was going to be fine so
they were selling contracts at a lower
price
then turned around and bought it even
lower and made like a [ __ ] ton of money
was a short position steve look we
actually came up to the end of the show
man we really appreciate you being on
you got it i want to first off you need
to do a podcast once a week about this
stuff i think people would actually
really enjoy it
i'm giving it some thoughts stop giving
a thought you [ __ ] jesus christ pull
the trigger
god damn it i've been telling you for
like two years now [ __ ] do it
and and of course if you want i'm going
to plug your twitter if you want to
follow steve on twitter
it's steve it's not that exciting i
promise it's
jesus christ stops jesus
baseball tweets and [ __ ] like that
whatever it's steve t
313 that's steve t 313
steve is a good dude i said it earlier
but i'll say it again steve is not as
steve is one of those dudes whenever
there's a hurricane
like coming he goes and helps put up so
ladies put shutters up
and he recently gave his dad his kidney
like he's a really legitimately good guy
you need some you need to promote
yourself better bud
you need a manager i mean did you at
least i'm humble did you at least like
charge him
for the kidney yeah no you don't charge
him why he's getting a
[ __ ] kidney he's your dad hey
yeah it's my dad come on man yeah i've
made enough stupidity decisions in the
past that he didn't kill me i think
steve's gonna short steve's shorting his
kidney
i'd be like i'd be like i get it but
like
not good enough like what else you got
what do you have on you right now
like yeah that's still going to get mad
at him i told him i wish he was a drunk
because then i wouldn't actually have to
lose the organ just chunk off a piece of
your liver it grows like a starfish
amen thanks for being on steve i
appreciate it man you're welcome on the
show anytime hey my pleasure boys
no problem you give me a call anytime uh
all right buddy take it easy
see you later all right take care all
right that's our buddy steve here